♪♪
We'll be ready for you in
five.
♪And now we meet in an abandoned
studio♪
♪We hear the playback and it
seems so long ago♪
Director:
Okay, places everyone.
From the top.
♪Oh-a oh-a♪
♪You were the first one♪
Sheila:
Let's do this thing.
Babe. Seriously, the coffee.
Tap tap tap tap tap tap.
God forbid you have anything...
valuable to do.
♪Video killed the radio star♪
Cheese puff?
-No!
Punch punch punch punch.
Mama.
-Ouch.
You're teaching class?
Olivia:
5-6-7...
Yeah.
I didn't know you liked people
enough to do that.
I'm a big fan of people.
(And skanky bottle blonde)
Sheila:
Only you have the power to
change you.
Sheila:
Are you ready to change?!
♪Video killed the radio star♪
You feeling better?
I feel more awake than I have
in...
Sheila:
I can't remember.
What's in this?
Sugar free pink lemonade and speed.